I think the founders were weren't
wearing enough of democracy actually hi
I'm Nick Gillespie with reason TV and
today we're talking with David Hasani
he's a syndicated columnist we run his
stuff at reason.com he's a senior editor
at The Federalist we'll talk about that
but first we're going to talk about his
newest book the people have spoken and
they are wrong the case against
democracy David thanks for talking to us
thanks for having me the case against
democracy laid out succinctly well there
are three levels to it one I have a
philosophical problem with the idea that
if a ton of people say something's right
or moral that it is secondly have a big
problem with a ton of people saying
something was moral and then coercing me
to act like them and and do the things
they want and thirdly have structural
problems with democracy as a way of
governing because it doesn't work very
well okay and well let's start with
voting you know you you slag voting a
lot in this you have a great quote from
Oriana Falacci the great italian
journalist saying i would rather spit my
own face than vote you know what's the
trouble what's the problem with voting
this is well isn't this what our
forefathers died for the right to vote
no I don't think so but I mean I think
we put a lot of value into voting that
we shouldn't because there are more
important things than voting when we
talk about freedom are always talking
about the vote not about a constitution
that protects our individual freedoms
our right to say what we want to not be
spied on to assemble things like that
we're always concentrating on a vote as
if that means freedom which it doesn't
democracy is just the process it
reflects the morals and ethics of the
people who vote it doesn't guarantee you
freedom just check out the gaza strip or
Egypt or anywhere so well here's a
question because so you're I mean your
basic argument is that democracy you
know is a process but what you're
talking about what's great about America
is the Constitution which limits the
power of government which limits the
size and scope of government and so we
shouldn't praise democracy because
that's really just mob yeah we should
also praised that democracy is diffused
in so many different ways that we can
live in our own communities the way we
want I lived in Colorado for many years
you know there's Boulder very liberal
and there's a Colorado Springs very
conservative I can live in either one
without the other two you know telling
us what to do just because they have a
bigger population one so well here's the
question
because what I was going to say is a you
know but the the Constitution ultimately
you know was voted on by people and it
you know a majority of people are put
together behind closed doors or all of
this and you know so why you know AB
what how do you know that mob rule or
majority rule is not a problem and you
know what's wrong with Boulder being
very liberal in Colorado Springs being
very conservative there's nothing the
problem happens when you have Boulder
trying to tell Colorado Springs how to
live their lives or vice versa I think
the founders were weren't wearing enough
of democracy actually I think there are
bigger problems with it listen the
biggest fascists I've ever met as a
reporter we're on school boards right or
condo board so I don't like the process
anyway but when you have a centralized
government in Washington that can coerce
people to buy health care that you know
that they decide I can't move to another
town or another state and live my life
the way I want to and this goes with
society's norms as well for instance
marriage I I think government should get
out of marriage not keep redefining it
as to you know do whatever the whims of
society are but then at what level of
governance would people be allowed to
say okay well you know what we are going
to allow spying in this community or we
are going to define marriage as between
one man and one duck you know in rick
santorum's duck and even drew I'm up for
it but nobody you know is is there a
place in your scheme then to say that's
my other heart pounds well that's why
you have a constitution to stop that
sort of thing I mean in the end we have
to have some kind of democratic process
to like people to run things but we
don't have to give them ultimate power
over just you know over the Constitution
and even at the more local level like
two are we supposed to cede more power
to the smaller to a kind of smaller
level of government because we can move
from there and also because the closer
democracy is to you the more us you know
the more it reflects the constituents
there you know America is a huge place
with a lot of different ideas that the
closer we have government that doesn't
make it always all right but it makes it
I think it gives us a little bit of a
more guarantee that you're going to
reflect the community in a better way
okay so in the book you also then you
come out in favor of gridlock you know
this is one of the bent noir is of good
government types everywhere both
conservatives in
liberals are complaining backward like
we can't get anything done what's the
case for gridlock well first of all
that's the voters fault to believe that
ninety six percent of voters think
Congress is doing a terrible job I think
inadvertently because they're a bunch of
idiots there but they are doing a great
job and stopping government cold and you
know you have you have a liberal
governor or liberal president and you
have a huge policy change in Obamacare
and then you have a reaction to that
it's organic I think and then it stops
everything so I'm very happy that we
have gridlock I think is wonderful I
mean I think what's happened so with you
know cases like the debt limit or you
know funding for the next year is it you
know is a good thing just to have
government be so incompetent that it
can't even write its own checks and you
know sometimes I wonder that you know
they'll sink the economy that's because
government's too big to start with but
they always pretty much get it done I
think that we have sort of widespread
panic in the media that's not there in
real life real people we get the debt
limit will be will be will raise and
we'll get it done I mean I I think that
you can see that ever in the end there
is some sort of compromise compromise
comes together because you have a
disagreement and at some point you have
to get it done and they do it is kind of
fascinating that you know nobody ever
says that Obama should compromise on his
nominees it's that they should be
appointed without any question well and
but then it did rarely that that
courtesy rarely get success because of
the incompetents of Republicans to make
a compelling argument about their case
which sometimes they don't have a very
good one frankly but I think you'll see
now if the Republicans win the Senate is
everyone you know a lot of people think
they will you see Obama vetoing bilson
and I won't hear about gridlock anymore
you hear about someone saving the
Republic yeah do you are you hopeful
that you know with 2016 or further down
the line that will actually build a
consensus for a smaller government and
government will do whatever it takes
actually resize the so you know cut the
size of government not really because I
think people feel libertarian about the
world but they don't vote libertarian
that often I i I'm somewhat hopeful
because I think younger people are I
think you may have written about this
younger people are skeptical about big
institutions and I'm talking about
government but also crony capitals and
things like that I think that's a
wonderful wonderful wonderful
development but the
but they're still very liberal and they
believe in sort of authoritarian power I
think a little bit too much so we'll see
I mean ya know it's just a new poll on
Millennials came out saying that they
are deeply distrustful of government and
other large institutions but more than
any other sector of the population they
believe that government should be bigger
I provide more service and I wonder I
think they're just probably like
everyone else I think they'll just like
their parents in the end frankly in it
yeah it wasn't the father of a
millennial I don't know who if he or me
would be more depressed by that well
let's talk about one of the things
you're doing up beyond the book is also
working with the Federalists this is a
relatively new website publication
you're a senior editor there tell us
about the Federalists well we started I
guess six months ago with founders Ben
Domenech and Molly Hemingway's there
Sean Davis and we are trying to appeal I
think two people who who don't want the
quick hits like you see a lot now who
have sites but like a little bit of a
deep dive on cultural things and not
simply just always politics
twenty-four-seven not a site that's
always dashing liberals 24-7 but a more
thoughtful approach and that's not to
say we don't need that and you know I
wrote think it's it's I'm not not
horrified by the thought of people
attacking each other and partisan ways
but we try to be more maybe like a
magazine might be in the old Indian
older style what why is it called the
Federalist wheel of federalism we are
Federalists there but I think that we
lean towards the sort of new libertarian
populism and so it was much discussed a
few months it yeah why do you think
libertarian populism why did that grab
many people in the kind of the public
imagination what what does libertarian
populism offer thats a regular
conservativism doesn't or you know non
adjectival libertarianism I think it's
really may be repurposed fusion ISM you
know I think it's it's a way to bring
together a lot of different groups under
on the right under you know sort of the
Tea Party types but also libertarians
maybe under under one umbrella I think
it appeals to people because most people
think they're libertarians on some level
and so we can offer them a little here
and there but I mean populism is
something as you can tell from my book
I'm not crazy about the word and
I think that I wish there was a better
moniker for it yeah well we will leave
it there the site is the Federalists and
the book by david hassan ii is the
people have spoken and they are wrong
the case against democracy david thanks
for talking to thank you for reason TV
i'm nicholas lee